As detail-oriented as Game of Thrones usually
is, the fantasy drama has featured not one
but two immersion-breaking mistakes during
its final season on television.
After spotting a stray coffee cup that was
accidentally left in a shot on the fourth
episode of Thrones season 8, viewers noticed
yet another erroneous object in frame on the
series finale.
Weirdly enough, this embarrassing gaffe is
also beverage-based, making it seem like the
crew on the final season of the show may have
had a bit of a drinking problem.
Spoilers ahead!
Following Daenerys Targaryen's fire-and-fury
siege of King's Landing that killed thousands
of innocent people, Tyrion Lannister resigned
as her Hand and asked Jon Snow to find the
strength to make a difficult decision that
would ensure the safety of the Seven Kingdoms:
kill Dany so she doesn't harm anyone else
under the guise of "liberation."
Fast forward a few weeks, and Tyrion emerges
for his trial - which turns into a meeting
of the minds with members of the remaining
Great Houses of Westeros, who decide that
they will now and forevermore choose the king
or queen.
Just as Tyrion is walking up to everyone,
the camera flips perspective to show Samwell
Tarly, Edmure Tully, and an unknown character
watching the last Lannister sibling approaching.
Keep your eyes on Sam during this moment,
and you'll see a plastic water bottle near
his foot.
It's about half hidden behind his boot, but
it's definitely noticeable.
Looks like actor John Bradley was getting
parched during Tyrion's big speech, which
is understandable ...
"Listening to talkers makes me thirsty."
Later on in the scene, a second water bottle
can be spotted behind Ser Davos Seaworth.
Must have been a hot day in the Dragon Pit.
Plastic water bottles are obviously very out
of place in Westeros …
"I'd skin you alive for wine.
F--- water!"
… and the first of the two errors stuck
out to tons of watchers at home.
Just as viewers were split over Season 8 as
a whole, they were also divided Water Bottle-gate.
One fan wrote.
"Seven hells, they did it again.
It's a plastic water bottle."
Another was frustrated to the point of all-caps-tweeting
after spotting the plastic water bottle in
frame, writing,
"PLEASEEEEEEEEEE.
THERE WAS A PLASTIC WATER BOTTLE IN THIS EPISODE.
NOT AGAIN."
Voice actor Troy Hughes was equally as upset,
finding it hard to believe that the Game of
Thrones crew could allow oversights like these
in the finale.
He wrote,
"Seriously!!!
It's the finale of #GameOfThrones … EVERYBODY
is watching … and you leave a water bottle
on the set?!?!"
CBS Sports writer Will Brinson felt that the
bottle blunder was a microcosm of the last
two seasons of Thrones.
He tweeted,
"Game of Thrones leaving a plastic water bottle
sitting there in the finale is such perfect
symbolism for a show that spent the last two
seasons rushing to get done and ignoring the
important little details that made it great
in the first place."
Conversely, plenty of others thought that
the mistake was ultimately harmless.
One viewer tweeted,
"First a Starbucks coffee cup and now a water
bottle.
I love it!
[It's] super silly!"
Another joked that HBO must have secured a
couple of sponsorships for the final season
of Game of Thrones:
"Let's all clap for the sponsors of this season.
The plastic water bottle and the Starbucks
cup."
Someone else even defended the Game of Thrones
team, noting that "framing isn't easy" and
the crew might have been paying closer attention
to the actors' performances, the lighting,
and the costumes than whether there were any
water bottles visible in the shot.
For some fans, everything that was supposed
to be included in the Game of Thrones finale
is more than enough to make them forget about
the out-of-place beverage.
For others, the water bottle mishap serves
as another nail in the coffin of a season
they weren't all that satisfied with.
Like Tyrion said during his rousing finale
monologue, there's nothing more powerful in
the world than a good story - but there's
nothing that can tarnish a tale like Game
of Thrones as easily as an absent-minded slip-up.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.